la agencia europea del medicamento no se
reúne hasta el próximo 21 de diciembre
pero la presidenta de la comisión
europea usa la sonda la hayan ya
avanzado que los países europeos
empezarán sus campañas de vacunación con
la vacuna de facer los próximos 27 28 y
29 de diciembre estos tres días los
países europeos tendrán que empezar sus
campañas ya que era muy difícil que
realmente todos los países pudieran
empezar el mismo día porque cada uno
tiene su propio plan de vacunación pero
está añade un poco más de presión a la
agencia europea que tiene que analizar
todos los datos y ver si en su próxima
reunión aprueba el fármaco tenéis todas
las a una europa que está ansiosa de
buenas noticias especialmente los
últimos días en que varios países
europeos han tenido que volver las
restricciones pero un aumento de los
contagios actualmente la unión europea
tiene asegurados 300 millones de dosis
de la vacuna de spicer que podrían
ampliarse si hace falta en total
bruselas tiene contratos con seis
farmacéuticas para
y suficientes millones de dosis para
toda la población europea